he was bisexual though duh what do you  mean of course he's bisexual  no no no  and uh I say bye to be like politically  great but I think he was just like gay  there are accounts of him uh sleeping in  the same room as his bodyguard with his  bodyguard which is it's like okay dude  you're gay then no he's gay like his  back then yeah yeah no yeah he was so  safe where was that body guard exactly  maybe they were having a they were  having a little tiff they were fighting  you can watch her play by yourself he  likes musicals  guard is furious he doesn't get to go  the one thing they get to do together  yeah it's like yeah no go go with your  [ __ ] wife